hmmm what's new on Netflix today Oh a TV
show based off the grudge let's take a
look at this odd Japan poetry plays sexy
times puppet shows let me first start
off by saying I've never been a fan of
Japanese horror I know I know but
there's just something about things
crawling out of TVs and whatever the
hell this is that just doesn't do it for
me
that being said I was actually pretty
excited when I heard Netflix was coming
out with a new show based off the grudge
from the trailer it looked like a
fast-paced mystery spanning decades
trying to solve why this creepy ass
house is making people go crazy and
commit insane murders boy was I wrong
but before we get into just how
ridiculous this show really is a make
sure to LIKE and subscribe because my
soul is slowly dying from watching all
this crap jus on origins begins in 1988
where we meet this guy Yasuo
or the Jima who's some guy who collects
stories about haunted houses and turns
them into books now where have I seen
this before I'm sorry I should have told
you I'm a fan he becomes obsessed with
the story of Haruka whose fiance died as
a result of visiting this house and when
he and Haruka go to his funeral they
found out his face was so disfigured
they couldn't even have an open casket
service but the mom is like please
please look at my dead son kind of weird
but I'm here for it and then this
happens now come on they couldn't spruce
this guy up a little bit I don't know
maybe add a little flowers I'm just
saying they could have done it at the
same time we meet our secondary
protagonist Kiyomi kawaii she's moving
to a new school after having an affair
with the teacher but spoiler alert it
was actually her mom who had the affair
but it gets better this character is so
over the top she accuses her daughter of
sleeping with the father who apparently
is dead I don't know what this is but
it's kind of hot so Kiyomi starts at her
new school and instantly makes some
friends bonding over their love of cats
they even invite her to an old abandoned
house known as the cat mansion and
immediately I'm like fooled abandoned
cat mansion I'm in the girls meet up
with this stud you die and break into
the house only for Kiyomi to be held
against her will and forcibly roped and
what do you do when you're committing an
unspeakable crime why take photos of
course
Kiyomi is left completely broken she
ends up going upstairs and cries alone
in the closet when I kid you not three
minutes later after all this happened
makes out with a guy who just ripped her
now I originally thought she'd get
possessed and rip his dick off or
something but no and this dude basically
goes from Kiyomi to this girl back to
Kiyomi
he's like the Bill Cosby of Japanese
haunted houses that's a no-no at the
same time there's this C storyline about
a child abductor and at first I thought
this was this young girl's dad because
the girl didn't seem in distress at all
but then this happens apparently a day
later Kiyomi is now in a relationship
with the guy who robbed her oh and
kiyomi's mom has legit only been in town
for a day and has already banked
kiyomi's teacher nice
so Kiyomi reads a letter to her mother
telling her she's going to leave and the
mom is like get the [ __ ] out I don't
care
and then she instructs you die to kill
her mom or else she's gonna go to the
police with those photos I knew those
photos would come back fast-forward six
years later to 1994 and you die works at
a garbage facility get it because he's a
trash human well he takes out his rage
on Kiyomi who I think is his wife now
and he's pissed because their
five-year-old Toshiki doesn't like him
so he beats the crap out of him putting
him in a vegetative state calm down now
you're probably thinking we haven't
talked about the house a lot and it's
been six years well a new couple has
moved in and this is where things start
to get really bonkers the husband here
is cheating with a pregnant woman a
pregnant woman who is having his baby at
the same time that pregnant lady's
husband is following her
and knows that she's cheating and later
that night at dinner she tells him the
baby is in his so he proceeds to drink
his entire glass of wine and says this
his attempt at making her chug wine
doesn't go over too well and he goes to
throw up in the washroom when she comes
in and stabs him in the back I mean I
gotta hand it to this guy he was just
stabbed in the back and he's like babe
don't over exert yourself think of the
baby anyway he ends up killing her is
like [ __ ] the baby and then oh no no no
no what what are you doing later that
same evening the baby miraculously lives
for a few hours until he buries it in
the backyard of that abandoned house and
somehow the other guy has hung himself
for some reason I I don't know why it's
never quite explained probably the house
and then her dude is walking home like
don't mind me just got stabbed in the
back nothing to see here
he's later arrested and questioned for
the murder and while in his cell we get
this gem of a scene oh my god it's so
cute okay okay what are you doing there
little fella well he just wants to see
he just wants to see daddy okay kind of
kinky but let's see where this goes
[Music]
so kiyomi's a prostitute now Yuda is a
junkie who gets his kidney stolen she
tells him Toshiki isn't his kid
but that the house gave it to her anyway
she ends up killing you died in what can
only be described as the world's
smallest bathtub
I knew Japanese apartments were small
but this is ridiculous
remember that guy from episode one who
goes around collecting ghost stories
well he basically does nothing for four
episodes until he's finally like hmm
maybe I should investigate that house
where a lot of murders happen he ends up
joining forces with a detective who lets
him visit the house and when he's there
he experiences flashbacks yet ready for
this he's somehow forgotten that he used
to live in this house when he was
younger I guess the trauma of seeing
this will do that to you there's a lot
of dropping babies on this one of the
cool parts of this show that really
isn't explored too deeply is that those
who are affected by the curse or the
house interact across time with one
another for example young Yasuo here in
the 1950s sees this creepy shadow woman
breaking through the glass but we find
out that this was actually Kiyomi in
1995 I thought this was a really awesome
gimmick but this show just doesn't go
anywhere with it and you don't even find
out it's a thing until the final two
episodes so two years passed after the
murders and a new couple moves in yeah
so warns them they should leave but
buddy guy over here is like we paid dirt
cheap for this place who cares if a
couple dozen people over the past
decades have died here I'm gonna get my
money's worth but one night they're
visited by the ghost of its past victims
and do the only logical thing have a
seance and it's here we kind of get an
idea of how the grudge Monster
originated in the early 1950s a man kept
a woman imprisoned in the house and
impregnated her she was tortured and
beaten until one day she ends up killing
him and dying herself after giving birth
now she has this grudge on anyone who
comes into the home get it the movie was
called The Grudge anyway so the seance
causes some crazy flashbacks the new
owner's wife goes into labor
and when he's asked if he wants to go
with her to the hospital he's like I'll
go later your wife just went to labor my
dude
so Yasuo ends up seeing the ghost of his
father outside the house but in reality
it's actually the new owner and then a
simultaneous flashback young Yasuo also
sees his father and this happens he just
somehow turns into goo okay a couple
months pass and Yasuo has written a new
book about his experience with a house
he's visited by the detective who is
curious to know how he knew one of the
victims had a telephone buried in her
stomach a fact that was only known to
police
Yasuo said he made it up and it's just a
coincidence yeah okay and as soon as the
detective leaves we learn that yeah so
is working with the house somehow over
the course of the show Yasuo wonders why
the house has killed everyone but spared
him and now he's realized his true
purpose the house let him live to spread
the word about it so that it can get
fresh victims and the show ends with
Haruka a really pointless character
going back to the house where all this
crazy [ __ ] has just happened only to get
killed by one of the ghosts that's it
that's the ending I mean I guess the
purpose of this series is to show the
origin of the grudge monster but
honestly this whole season could have
been way more interesting in an hour and
a half long movie I just showed you guys
the more interesting parts of it but
it's pretty boring for the most part if
you want something with an amazing
ending check out another foreign show on
Netflix called dark I've done tons of
videos on it and it's seriously
addicting that's it for this video guys
make sure to LIKE and subscribe and
leave a comment below for more bad takes
you can follow me on twitter at big
story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much